will be waiting
for you
why would you be waiting for me why
would you be waiting for me johnny depp
had his fair share of embarrassing and
downright awkward moments while
portraying the swashbuckling pirate from
unfortunate age gaps to line flubs to
trouble with executives depp's
adventures in the franchise and beyond
are nothing short of interesting bad
luck dogs you day and night now that is
a place of publication
number one
it doesn't sound so bad but
a pretty significant age gap made the
fact that johnny depp had to kiss keira
knightley and pirates of the caribbean
very uncomfortable for the actor depp
who was 42 at the time was exactly
double the age of 21 year old nightly
intimacy on set can be a bit awkward as
it is especially in the time before
intimacy coaches became the norm on sets
but everything around this particular
situation was off-putting for death he
explained any kind of scene like that
whenever you're doing that sort of thing
it's always unbelievably awkward
especially having met kira when she was
17 years old yeah it's a bit tough to
look past that history luckily the whole
situation wasn't too bad for nightly at
all who felt totally comfortable and
rolled with the flow even depp was
surprised by how much ease the actress
showed saying she was a good sport and
we just kind of did what we had to do
that's the gig
number two
one excellent improv scene coming right
up anyone remember this scene from dead
man's chest the one when jack sparrow
gets extra feisty calling jones all
right fish fights and then of course
there's all the havoc afterwards poking
fun at the jar of dirt and singing
through it all i got a drawer
i got a jar to do and guess what's
inside it depp just went full tilt in
terms of character with this one making
embarrassingly wacky choices that
somehow just turned out right
number three
testing testing one two three johnny
depp had a secret weapon in his ear
before hitting the set in costume hair
makeup all the details depp included one
other step inserting his earpiece in the
later films and pirates of the caribbean
depp made regular use of a sound
engineer whose gig was to essentially
feed the lines to johnny through an
earpiece unable to keep up with his
dialogue anymore and not wanting to
appear like he was missing a single beat
depp had to resort to this method which
is pretty surprising considering what a
pro he is
number four
you can't take the jack sparrow out of
johnny depp and you can't take the depth
out of the jack sparrow captain jack
sparrow
but at one point the behavior of both
was not flying so well with the
producers filming his very first turn as
jack sparrow depp got a call from a
disney exec who essentially asked what
was wrong with him questioning why he'd
been performing the pirates so
chaotically in the end of it depp
adjusted his performance just a bit but
it was quite embarrassing for the actor
to be pulled aside and spoken to about
his performance especially with such
higher ups being so concerned and
disappointed
number five
who put that there when you're trapped
on this set you really are stuck it's
hard to have any kind of dignity when
you've been scooped up and are at the
mercy of a bag and the set coordinators
who are in control of it depp may have
been the leading man in the film and a
major player but in this scene he was
just a guy stuck trapped in a bag we
can't imagine this was one of his fun
scenes
number six
dangerous and awkward all at the same
time when one has a sword in hand and
it's coming close to another's face
you've gotta be worried with all that
pressure and tension johnny depp cracked
i'm touched at this most sincerest
and then he did it again i'm touched at
this moment
and then again
you get the picture at least the actor
was honest and owned up to his endless
flubs i think the stakes going very well
don't you
it was going well for the blooper reel
that's for sure
number seven
aim is key on film sets and so is follow
through it seems like johnny depp really
suffered with both as he awkwardly
fumbled his cups oh so shamelessly the
fact is depp could hardly even laugh it
off because of how embarrassingly bad an
attempt of a throw it was there were
some rough days on the sea there's no
denying that the pirate struggle is real
number eight
names can be hard to get straight to be
fair the names of the ship's characters
and places in the series are pretty
elaborate and definitely not what we're
used to but depp had a particularly hard
time remembering some of them
he'd be on a roll ready to go in
character and fabulous and then
this would happen what's the bloody
thing called
flying dutchman a pirate's life is a
wildlife
number nine
the party don't stop on the sea hey if
you're gonna work like a sailor then you
best party like a pirate but in this
scene well whatever it seems to be might
have been a bit too strong for johnny
what's in there
while there weren't any illicit
substances in those glasses johnny was
struggling to make it work and keep his
cool maybe we could chalk it up to
seasickness
number ten
quiet on set there's a reason they say
that before the cameras start rolling
are you certain
honestly any little thing in a set can
disturb an actor's concentration and
totally ruin the moment and in this case
well
depp wasn't about to pass up the chance
to take advantage of the opportunity to
crack a good joke number 11
speaking can be harder than you think
depp was slipping up continuously
throughout every single film his charm
got him through but there was definitely
a point when the clock started ticking
and there was a crunch to film
everything on time
okay
he was all in in terms of character but
sometimes you just lose those words
i'll get it this time i promise and he
would get it eventually
number 12.
it's a look okay so this happened after
filming but it wouldn't have happened
had it not been for the jack sparrow the
pirate has gold capped teeth because of
course he would but once they wrapped up
shooting depp still wore them not just
by accident either the actor wore them
after the first and second movie a
strange choice for sure his reasons when
asked why he continued to show off the
gold teeth well the actor claimed it was
just in case reshoots were ever needed
number
13. once a swordsman always a swordsman
especially when you suddenly don't seem
to know how to use a sword anymore this
was the unfortunate reality for johnny
depp and mordecai oh
i see that you have been schooled in the
fine art of fencing the actor's sword
fighting skills shown were pretty
embarrassing for everyone but for the
captain jack sparrow that hollywood grew
to know and love it was pretty
humiliating
number 14
let's take a trip to wonderland filming
alice in wonderland saw anne hathaway
working with a very admired colleague
the one and only johnny depp she was
nervous to work with him and the
situation became entirely worse because
when the two of them were filming
hathaway started to stare a little too
intently at depth causing him to notice
and then
sitting in awkward silence wound up
being that much worse when there was
nothing else to look at but green
screens and each other
number 15
depp doesn't love to talk about this one
this was the project that made him known
but it's not work that the actor ever
really wants to talk about he described
it as being in a prison creatively he
literally hated doing the job so much
that he started trying to get himself
fired by acting out and trashing his
trailer but his complete disdain for
that part of his career didn't stop him
from making a little cameo in the 21
jump street film with channing tatum and
jonah hill
his career has had a whole lot of ups
and downs but at the end of the day he's
still brought us some spectacular
performance and a whole lot of laughs
which embarrassing scene was your
favorite